hey what's up man I just cuz the goal
concerns wrong pasty I had a brother and
he's recently come across some meat that
my sister gives him and she's actually a
truck driver oh yeah I know what she's
talking about dude that's a just family
meat man homework so she gets a lot of
exotic meat throughout the Midwest and
she off was a couple of couple of pounds
of ostrich
so my brother and you know he's been
eating every day and he's it's kind of
like he that it's not like he has its
any pictures every day is just a little
weird and I'm wondering what's your idea
of that man like truck driver Wow burden
me you know you think it might be going
to his brain a little bit anyways man
thanks man I hope you're doing good
thanks brother back at you man oh I
think if you have a little bit of
stretch butter ain't nothing wrong with
you you know there ain't nothing wrong
you wake up in the morning have a couple
eggs and I hit a stretch you know not
everybody gets to have ostrich so maybe
you know you should you know your
brother's lucky to have that delicacy
baby you know some people that say you
can't eat this and you can't eat that
and I say this watch me okay unless
you're gonna come by my house and stand
by my plate I might have a little
something okay
sometime I might have me a little cut a
Hulk alright I might have me a little
basket uh or how I might have me half a
basket of seal Nuggets alright y'all
don't tell me what I can have and what I
can't y'all never know I might have a
little bit of canary brittle for I shut
it down for a night I might have some
adolescent back ribs I might bring a
nine in the joint and have a Popeye's
chicken sandwich okay I might have
something rare I might have a little bit
of uh you know I might have some
Doberman
on brioche or some carp tarts or some
goldfish fillets with a little bit of a
reindeer remoulade drizzle everybody has
different desires so if you got a little
bit of stretch over there if your ladies
drop you know visiting another man and
dropping off a little bit of that
freaking long neck Oh meat to him well
more power to them brothers family you
know what I hate the most is when my
sister drives past my house and don't
bring me it so thank you for calling man
and I hope everybody out there drops off
some rare meat to somebody that they
love thank you guys for checking out
this clip and if you want to see another
clip then you can look at this clip or
this clip either one of these so did you
pick one or he's still just watching me
do this because this is alarming